What's going on guys? Mr. Zinc here. In
today's video, we're going to break down
gaps. One of these gaps on the screen
right now has a sub 60% win rate. The
other has a 94% win rate. Quite
obviously, the one that is highlighted
in green is the one that you should be
using, although not many people know how
to identify it nor know how to use it.
The red rectangle, the red gap, is the
one that has a sub60% win rate. This is
the gap that most traders highlight
because it is easy to identify is the
8:00 PM close to 4 a.m. open gap. Most
traders think this is the draw for the
day every single day. However, this gap
doesn't always fill. When it does pop
up, sometimes it fills, sometimes it
doesn't.
The reason that we're looking at this
green gap and the reason that you need
to incorporate it into your trading
strategy is because it has a such a high
percent win rate, albeit it doesn't
really pop up that often. When it does
pop up, you should be sitting on the
edge of your seat waiting for this to
play out.
Now, I call this the previous day in
London gap. I don't entirely like the
name, so in the comments, drop what you
think we should call it. the most like
comment. That's the name that we'll pin
on the strategy. To get this gap,
mark out your previous days 50, previous
days high, previous days low, drag it
out to the right, and your London 50.
London low, London high, drag it out to
the right. The gap present between the
previous day's high and London low, or
let's say it was a gap that was down
here. the gap between previous days low
and London high. That is your previous
day and London gap. Now that we marked
that out, that has a 94% chance of
filling or being the draw for the day.
If you see price over this gap, you
should be anticipating a pullback right
into that zone until that whole gap is
filled, meaning that you filled down to
previous day's high. If it's below it,
you're looking for price to continue up
to fill up to previous day's low.
This happened twice this week. It
doesn't happen all that often. Usually
happens once, maybe two times a week if
you're lucky. The longest stretch that I
went without seeing one of these gaps
was
about 10 days. So, two full weeks.
Going to yesterday just to review how
this happens real time.
There's our previous day's 50.
Price opened 4 a.m. session
significantly above previous days high.
So we had a a pretty monster gap to
start the session. That was our gap
right there. If you woke up at 4 a.m. to
trade like a psychopath, that is your
draw. That what that's what you should
be anticipating. So you should be
hammering shorts. I'm not saying that
you enter shorts without a model, but
you should be highly anticipating price
to continue down to fill this gap at
previous day's high. Now, London session
developed and the gaps are getting
smaller and smaller and smaller. We go
to the next candle and it slowly started
filling down. And there you go. Right
before open yesterday, the 9:15 candle
filled that. So then we mark out our
London range and we no longer have the
gap present. So we have no draw on the
day. We have a bullish bias for the day
as we're over previous days 50 and we're
looking for a push up to either London
50 from previous days high and London
low.
And I already know what happened because
we traded it yesterday. There's our push
up to London 50. Full PT met on that
trade. Closed the charts for the day
right there.
As you can see, this gap does not pop up
very often. When it does, it has that
94% win rate. This gap is the one that
many, many, many traders mark out
because it's easy to identify. It's easy
for you to see, hey, this is a massive
gap between previous days high or London
low. No, that's not the case. This is a
gap between the 800 PM close and the 4
a.m. open. In this case, this is a
Friday into Monday gap. So, these ones
are the new week opening gaps. These
typically fill at a higher percent
chance than the 60% sub 60% of the
typical 8:00 p.m. to 4 a.m. open. In
this case, this one filled.
Congratulations. You were looking in the
wrong spot and got a correct result.
What typically happens is this right
here. You have a gap between 8:00 p.m.
and 4 a.m. open. This is a Wednesday
into Thursday. The gap fills maybe 40%
of it and then price rockets to the
upside for the rest of the day. If you
were sitting here anticipating price to
fill this gap because it's an easy one
to identify, you're hearing it from
other influencers, whatever it might be,
change up what you're looking at and
look for the gap between previous days
high and London low. Marking out
previous day's high. I'm not going to
mark out the whole thing. and then
marking out London low which is
hit three times in a row right here. Do
you see a gap between those levels? No.
So you have no draw for the day. In this
case, we had a move over previous day's
50. So here's our previous day's range.
Drag it out to the right. We have a
bullish bias for the day. Here's our
London 50.
Price bounced right at the London 50
right at open. Given our bullish bias,
we have no draw because there's no gap
between London low and that previous
day's high. Looks like I drew a little
incorrect there. There we go. Price just
rocketed it off previous day's high,
London 50 continued up for the entire
day. What you want to do with the
strategy is you want to back test it on
your own. You want to make sure that
you're identifying where it's located,
what happens when price hits it, how
long does it take, all that stuff. In
this case, we had a gap between previous
days high and London low. Did it fill
right at open? No. But we still had a
bearish bias for the day. Even though we
were over previous days 50, we had a
bearish bias because of the significance
of this previous day in London gap.
Drag it out right there. And if you can
tell, this one filled all the way at the
last candle, the 345 15minute candle.
the very last candle of the day filled
that strategy, filled that gap. Sorry.
So, it it might not fill right at open,
might not fill at 1:00, might not fill
at 10:00 a.m. in the morning. This one
filled all the way at 3:45 in the
afternoon, 4:00 close even.
This is still a win on this gap because
it avoided or it helped you avoid going
into longs for the day. you have a
bearish bias waiting for that draw to
fill and then you move on into the next
day or you could have stayed in shorts
right at open. You might have had a
little draw down on them. You might have
a stop loss that London high
but the fill on this move
lines up with the 94% that we anticipate
on the strategy. Again,
zooming out. How many green rectangles
do you see on the screen?
Let me actually redraw this one in over
here. Exit replay mode. Yes. So, there
are a whopping two green rectangles.
Just picture this one still over there.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine, 10, 11 trading days. So,
one every five trading days, one every
five and a half, once a week, sometimes
twice a week if you're lucky. You have
this model pop up. You have your
previous day in London gap.
You should be sitting on the edge of
your seat waiting for that to fill.
Again, marking it out from today. Let me
clean up the chart here real quick.
Previous day's high. London
drawn out.
That gap filled right at about 10:30
this morning. 10:15, 10:30. I took a
long off the initial fill
which was on a wick,
bounced up, hit London 50. Let me go
down to a much smaller time frame so you
can see what I'm talking about here.
Get out of there. So, the initial fill
was right here and then it went all the
way back up to London 50 and then it
filled again and it went all the way
back up to London 50. So, two scenarios
where we had a 50 point move off of this
gap fill. After the third reaction, this
is no longer a valid level. Obviously,
I'm on the 15-second time frame, so
you're not going to be able to see the
wicks there. It's present on the 15
minute, but after you tap a level for
the third time, you can see real on on
the 15-minute real time, it slowly stops
losing its validation.
And then once it breaks, it flips. You
have three taps to the other side. In
this case, it only took one and then it
just free fell all the way basically to
previous day's low.
These are the gaps that you should be
playing, not the gaps between 8 p.m.
close and 4 a.m. open. I hope this video
helped out. Again, if you haven't seen
the London 50 strategy, make sure to
click on my channel, go check that out.
In the comments, drop the name for this
gap, what you think we should call it. I
don't really like the previous day in
London gap. Most like comment, that's
the name that we'll pin on this
strategy. Have a great rest of your day.
I'll see you guys later this week for
another video.